i love this man i don't care who knows
it i don't know how he does it and the
it is everything that he does
he is back here on the rich eisen show
chief washington correspondent
for cnn the host of the lead with jake
tapper state of the union with jake
tapper and he's got
a new novel out i love the hellfire club
it is a page turner
and the devil may dance i cannot wait to
read the latest novel from jake tapper
how are you jake
i'm so good and i and i love you so much
but i i don't know why
you bring up all the the one area where
we disagree
like we you and i agree on so many
things yes
in in life in in entertainment and
broadcasting
and you constantly bring up constantly
the one thing where we disagree and you
know what i've been holding this in
reserve
um but i you know
because of spoilers i don't want to
spoil the movie for people okay
but the pivotal moment in die hard
it's a pivotal moment where john mcclane
is not going to survive the whole
mission is going to be
a failure he is going to die holly is
going to be killed etc holly
is her name yes and then he sees a
christmas
display with presents and christmas tape
this is the climax of the movie and he
we don't know that he does this until
later with the christmas tape
that only exists because it's christmas
at nakatomi plaza he tapes
the gun to his back and thus
surprises the bad guy and saves the day
period spoilers i'm apologizing
it's it's it's it's it's it's been long
enough jake tapper and you're again
referring to the fact that um i say die
hard is not a christmas movie movie you
you say it is and we just showed that uh
set up for our peacock audience now our
radio audience joining us here
um i just set that just to set the stage
for the fact that for fans of yours jake
and i am one i'm a huge fan of yours i'm
the president of the
of the richard eisen family well we're
we're back and forth then i mean we're
seeing politico like that
that for fans of yours and fans of your
writing
that the fact that you have a new novel
coming out right now the devil may dance
comes out tomorrow just like die hard
it's like christmas in the summertime
[Laughter]
i appreciate that you know what i mean
like so people want to have their summer
vacation
and a page-turning book which is what i
did uh with the hellfire club uh
on a beach and it's perfect material for
that perfect perfect
so for their summers it's it's like
christmas arriving
uh out of season jake that's why i kind
of bring that
i appreciate it and i love it and i love
where you're going you're go
you're going to a positive place and i
appreciate it
just so you know people need to
understand that when you karaoke with
rich eisen
you are it is basically
you sit down and you just listen to rich
eisen sing sinatra songs for an hour
with a lovely voice a deep baritone well
but we need to say this jake um it's not
because i
hog the mic i just i'm just giving the
people what they want
you know it's required i take by request
in the room yes yes
no no okay you need to put asses in the
seats
100 that's what that's about it's not
hogging the mic
by by any stretch but my only point is
yes
i think you will really enjoy this book
because it presents sinatra as a person
as a character
uh it warts and all good things and bad
things and he is
the premise of the book is based on a
real story a real
thing that happened which is as you know
sinatra and the rat pack worked their
heart out to elect jfk
in 1960 uh and then sinatra felt that
when president kennedy came
to the to california at some point he
would
of course president kennedy would stay
with him uh at his rancho mirage
compound
and he had all sorts of construction
done to it he had rooms built he had
telephone lines put in he had a helipad
built and then attorney general robert
kennedy
uh was starting to get pinky about this
because he thought
you know i am fighting organized crime
here and sinatra literally is friends
with mobsters
he's sam giancanas has stayed at this
compound
i don't know if i can let my brother
stay there that's the true
story and that was the premise for
the devil may dance which is charlie and
margaret my main characters from the
hellfire club
he's a congressman she's a zoologist go
out
to investigate to find out if sinatra is
actually mobbed up
and he's in the middle of filming the
manchurian candidate and he meets all
these folks so i really
like even if none of your listeners buy
this book you
really will like this book and i mailed
you one so you should have it arriving
anytime soon sometime soon you will
really like it i guarantee it
i have i have the book jake and you know
i may or may not already have
a photograph that of me reading it
not staged at all when i post it on
instagram it's not staged at all
uh being totally engrossed by the
material
okay you will you will i can't wait and
at something else
there is a song in the book
called the devil may dance that that
um i wrote i did not write the melody
because i as you know do not have a good
picture well
the great sammy khan must have written
it right i mean
if you're going to go real here ben
houston i think was uh
but but this is you'll enjoy this so
when the lawyers are going over the book
to make sure that nobody can sue me
for them because they're all sorts of
people real people
most of them are dead but real people uh
in the book and the church of
scientology makes an appearance etc etc
well and the thing that's amazing jake
tapper here on the rich eisen show and i
will
uh gladly to your horn sir is again in
the hellfire club you mentioned
no no more first place no seriously
what you just mentioned you know one of
the characters
um margaret martyr is a zoologist i mean
brockman you read the hellfire club
i'm learning about i'm learning about
animals i'm learning about
everything about zoology i'm learning
about that stuff your research
in a fun way in a fun way it is no no it
is it's great
i'm not boring anybody this is my way to
point out that the research you do
is intense it's clear that you have
researched
everything every last detail and i'm
sure you
you you may have a person or people help
you with that but
no one there you go so when the hell do
you have time to do all this did you
write this
book while you're covering the 2020
election i wrote this book uh let's see
the
the first one came out in 2018 so i've
been i wrote it in 2018 2019 and 2020.
so i wrote it
during those periods um when when the
hell do you have time to do it
if you if you if you're in a writing
project and i assigned you a writing
project you might remember
a couple years ago i assigned you a book
and i did nothing with it jake
because i'm i'm a slacker compared to
that is the best seller you just have to
sit there but here's the deal
okay you already know all the stuff in
your book though i'm not going to spoil
it because that's your that's your
project okay
but if you if you are in the middle of a
writing project and if you promise to
yourself and you pledge to write 15
minutes a day
15 minutes ever you can find 15 minutes
in your day
lunch breakfast right before you go to
bed 15 minutes is not that hard
even if that's all you do at the end of
the week that's an hour 45 minutes of
writing that's
four pages three pages i mean that's not
nothing so it adds up
and but let me so anyway i was able to
do that plus
in 2020 i was at home broadcasting from
april through august so there's an hour
and a half commute i don't have anymore
uh plus you know normally i would be
traveling all over the country
covering the presidential race not so
much in 2020 i
i did two trips once to michigan to
interview biden and then
in december i drove to delaware to
interview him and the vice president
that was it those are my two trips
and no election year have i ever had so
little travel so i did so i had more
time on my hands than normal
but the thing i wanted to tell you about
the the fake sinatra song that i wrote
is
so the lawyers are going through it the
book to make sure that nobody can sue
yes
and they say you know you can only put
one line of a song
in a book because otherwise people will
sue you
the the whoever owns the rights to the
song will say that's our property you
can't do more than uh
fair use is one line period right um
so they're like you're tapping you're
crazy you you know
that you can only do one line we've been
through this before and you have an
entire sinatra song
in here the whole every lyric and it's
like wound through the climax of the
book which takes place at the
1962 oscars like what are you doing and
i said
it's not real i made it up it's not a
real song
and that was like this well you need to
put that in there because people are
going to go crazy trying to google it
trying to find it but that's like the
greatest compliment that you can get of
course i thought it was
real they thought it was real was also
the fact of the new york times in
reviewing it said that uh
what janet maslin said she missed the
book when she was done with it so
congrats on that man she's tough she
gave me she gave a middling review of my
first book so for her to give
such a nice review of this one meant a
tremendous amount to me
well i mean i couldn't be more happy for
you what do i do
with one of my friends here uh who you
met in dc
uh when you were on the show last who
finally took the recommendation of mine
to watch the manchurian candidate the
old sinatra film
that was a classic but then removed from
the theaters by frank himself because of
the assassination of john f kennedy and
how it could be somehow
construed for him to foreshadow it in
the in the brilliant movie
that he watched the first half of it
stopped watching it how long ago would
do did you stop watching it chris
it's got to be six months he hasn't
watched it again what do i do with that
you haven't watched he hasn't watched
the second half of that jake jake in my
defense
dude before you say what you've got
going on you just heard this man's work
ethic
okay what he's got going on in his life
and but jake as you might know
i have a one-year-old like i don't have
any time by the time he's got two
children
but they're not they're not one
at 7 30 every night because you guys
think christmas
uh christmas comes in the die hard
collection
but i will say that movie is
really ahead of its time and really
trippy like a really weird move like
i'm watching it now watching and i just
watched it uh
a few weeks ago um yeah
because because uh some of the book some
of my book takes place while they're
filming
this uh criterion asked me to do an
intro
to the manchurian candidate which is a
huge honor because i'm a huge fan of
old classic film so i watched it again
and oh my god it is such a weird movie
it is in a great way
very trippy way ahead of its time and
the idea
that it took place they came out
a year before jfk was assassinated um
where you know when the movie is about a
major political assassination
do you know this by the way do you know
that arthur crim
who was the head of universal i'm sorry
the head of united artists
which uh which released the film and
also a major democratic
fundraiser and advisor arthur crane put
a hold on it he would not let the movie
be made
and then sinatra had to go to hyannis
port beg president kennedy
please tell krim to let this happen this
is a great movie and and kennedy
had read the book uh and the book is
even more
trippy than the movie the the book the
mom
of the assassin there's actually like
actual incest that takes place in the in
the movie it's just like implied kind of
yes that's right with angela lansbury
and whatever but
yes and so kennedy's reaction was uh
that's great who plays who plays the mom
and uh
at the at the time they had not even
cast angela lansbury you know who's
sinatra wanted in the part lucille ball
true story oh wow hey jake i'm up
against the end of an hour as you know
uh to use a phrase that pays in the news
business so i'll have to leave it there
um i love you jake tapper congrats on
this book we'll chat again so much
i'll talk about that everybody get the
book it's
going to be amazing hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here